hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
a lot of you guys have been asking us
for help
deciding whether you should buy the new
m1 macbook air
or if you should go with the ipad pro
and the magic keyboard
so in this video we're going to be
comparing everything between these two
including the design the portability
playing games on them including world of
warcraft on the m1 macbook air
and performance so without further ado
let's jump
right into this comparison first off the
m1 macbook air starts out at 999 dollars
whereas the ipad pro is 800 plus
300 for the magic keyboard to turn it
into a
laptop replacement of course this model
of the m1 macbook air comes with the 7
core gpu
and just 8 gigs of unified memory but in
our testing it's been performing
incredibly well as you guys will see
later on in this video
now the first thing i want to do is
compare the designs
so let's close these up and take the
ipad pro
off of the magic keyboard and by the way
i have an xbox controller
and a mouse ready for the gaming test
later
but i'm going to put these aside for now
comparing the design
the ipad pro is obviously much smaller
and thinner you can see how much more
compact it is
compared to the macbook air and in terms
of the thickness
there's really no comparison so of
course the ipad pro has the advantage
for portability
if you're not using a case and that is
what the magic keyboard case
is for and what i love about this is
just how easy it is to get it on there
just
bam magnets it's on face id unlocked now
what's very interesting
is that with that magic keyboard case
the ipad pro actually gets a lot more
thick basically close to as thick as the
macbook air at the thickest point
and quite a bit thicker at the thinnest
point of the macbook air because it does
go down
now one of the biggest differences is
that the ipad pro comes with a rear
facing camera
so you get a wide camera you get an
ultrawide camera and you also get a
lidar scanner which is useful for
augmented reality apps and games now
going around the side of the ipad pro
you do get four
different speakers so it's more i guess
immersive than the macbook air but we
are going to be doing a speaker
comparison
in just a minute of course the ipad pro
has a usbc
port the main one right here but with
the magic keyboard case you
also get another port in the actual
hinge
of the case itself but this can only be
used for power
it can't be used for data transfer
whereas the macbook air
of course gets two thunderbolt ports
very fast ports
and you also get a headphone jack which
you do not get with the ipad pro now
this is
interesting you would think that the
ipad pro setup is lighter
but it actually feels like it's heavier
than the macbook air
which is a really weird feeling because
it's just so much more compact
so interestingly the weight is actually
very similar
between these two let's go ahead and
open them up as you can see
instant on on the macbook air and just
open up
the hinge like that boom look at that
face id logs you in automatically which
i really love
because it makes it so convenient for
downloading apps logging in compared to
touch id on the macbook air now with
these finally open we can start to
compare everything on the inside
including the displays that's actually
going to be the biggest difference
because you have 11 inches
on the ipad pro and you have 13 inches
on the macbook air and as you can see
you get a lot more screen real estate
here
on top of that i am noticing that you
get better display angles with the
macbook air you can
put it down lower and with the magic
keyboard with the ipad you can't really
do that as far now what's awesome this
year for the macbook air is that it
finally has
p3 wide color gamut support the ipad pro
used to have a huge advantage
being much more color accurate but now
the macbook air has caught up
however the ipad pro does get the
advantage of display brightness
it comes with 600 nits compared to
around
400 on the macbook air and just looking
at it from that top
angle camera the ipad pro is just so
much more bright
now there are a couple more major
display differences like
120 hertz technology on the ipad pro
apple pencil support of course the touch
screen
but before we get into all of that i do
want to move over
to the keyboards and the trackpads the
biggest standout difference is that the
macbook air comes with an extra row of
function keys the magic keyboard case
for the ipad pro
is missing that so that's one of the
disadvantages
now in terms of the keys themselves i
kind of feel like
the keys in the macbook air are a little
bit more clicky
have a little bit more sound whereas the
ipad pro keys are a little bit muted
however i am shocked because the keys in
the magic
keyboard case for some reason feel
just a little bit better than the ones
on the macbook air
now in terms of the track pads you guys
can instantly see
the difference in size the one on the
macbook air is
massive more than twice as big as the
one on the magic keyboard case
now i really love large track pads
especially moving over to the 15
and 16 inch macbook pro which have
massive track pads and i just feel like
you get extra freedom to move your
fingers around it's just so much more
convenient
now on the ipad pro apple is using their
own custom technology so
anywhere you click on the magic keyboard
trackpad it clicks
just like it does with the macbook air
so it doesn't use the traditional diving
board mechanism that i really don't like
so it feels really good
and on top of that it supports all of
the same gestures so you get
swipe support switching between apps
going to home
and you can also two finger click to
right click like on these apps as you
guys can see
two fingers right clicking same thing as
you get with the macbook air
however the macbook air uses the force
touch technology
so this trackpad doesn't actually move
what happens is when it senses you
clicking on it it vibrates
and it feels like it's clicking and it
also supports forced
touch so you can double click down
deeper
which feels really weird but it's
actually a great feature probably the
best track pad on
any computer there is now before we get
into comparing those display differences
let's get right into comparing the
speaker quality
[Music]
now we did record that using our
microphone right up there so
it might be a little bit biased towards
the macbook air because it has
up facing speakers compared to the ipad
pro which fire out the sides
but to my ears what i notice is that the
macbook air definitely has
higher or brighter highs and it almost
feels like they
dominate the whole sound where you can't
really hear the mids or the bass as well
now on the ipad pro the highs are tuned
down quite a bit
but the mids and the bass sound really
good you get really clean
sound quality so i'd say that the actual
sound quality
is better on the ipad pro but you get so
much more
volume with the macbook air now to me
i would rather have the higher volume
with the higher
highs i guess with the macbook air
because if you're watching something
like a show or
a movie it's just going to sound better
and louder
with that macbook air now i want to
quickly talk about the webcam experience
or using
zoom or skype between these two now with
the m1 macbook air
we are only getting a 720p webcam but
apple did add the new image signal
processor
within that m1 chip and honestly the
exposure is just
so much better than it was before that
i'd say
i am impressed by this 720p webcam now
with the ipad pro you get better quality
but here's the issue using the magic
keyboard case
if you're using it like this the webcam
is on the side
so if you're just looking at the display
it looks like you're not
kind of paying attention when in reality
you are so it's a little bit weird that
it's on the side
now in terms of the quality i definitely
say that the ipad pro
looks better but as you can see i'm
looking right at the display
and it definitely looks weird on the
ipad pro
now over on the macbook air it looks
like i'm paying attention
the quality is definitely not as good
but i am noticing that
the actual field of view is wider so you
can see more
and i think that looks a little bit
better than on the ipad pro which was a
little bit too
tight but you guys let me know how the
microphone quality
is comparing these two devices now with
all of that out of the way i want to
move back into the displays
the ipad pro has the added advantage of
having pro motion technology
which means that the display can refresh
at up to 120 hertz
so when you're using it like for things
like this web browsing
it's incredibly smooth and snappy
whereas this
this is stuck at 60 hertz and you can
instantly tell the difference
between these two let's say you're
watching a 24 fps video
the display refresh rate actually goes
down to 24 hertz to match it and that
helps
save battery life on the ipad pro
however
with the m1 chip the battery life is
just so much better with this macbook
air
it's rated for 15 to 18 hours
compared to just 10 with the ipad pro so
the macbook air is definitely the winner
for battery life now by far the biggest
difference between these two displays
is that the ipad pro of course has
a touchscreen so that is one of the main
reasons
if not the main reason why you would buy
the ipad pro
now of course the ipad pro supports this
the apple pencil
this right here is the reason why a lot
of people are going to be choosing the
ipad pro because you can take notes you
can draw
you can use professional drawing apps
editing apps
with a stylus a lot of people like that
experience to some people this is
incredibly important
and the performance of this is
incredible on the ipad pro
much better than on the other ipads
moving on let's go ahead and get into
performance
but before i start geekbench 5 which is
a really good cross
platform benchmark i do want to talk
about the app support
the macbook supports the traditional mac
os
apps so if you're looking for
professional app work
the macbook air has support for those
let's say
lightroom classic premiere pro davinci
resolve
a ton of other apps that you can only
get on
something like mac os now the benefit
this year with the m1
is that the macbook air can now support
apps like
let's say lumafusion as you can see
right there
lumafusion in ipad or iphone app
is available now on the mac os app store
the macbook air with the m1 now has
access to the massive
ios and iphone app library and even if
it doesn't show up in here
i'm going to show you guys a free method
of getting apps
that aren't available yet here onto the
mac
but with that let's go ahead and run the
cpu benchmark
now while this is running i do want to
mention that the ipad pro with the magic
keyboard
does do a good job for people like
students who need to use microsoft word
or other apps like that
this does a great job for things like
web browsing
media consumption and doing simple work
we got our scores back and this is
extremely impressive
the macbook air is getting 53 higher
single core performance that means it's
going to be much more snappy for things
like web browsing
tasks like that and in terms of
multi-core
it's a massive 60 percent more powerful
so the macbook air is definitely the one
you're choosing if you really take
performance work seriously of course we
also have the
metal compute benchmarks so let's run
that as well
all right we got our scores and i do
want to mention that this macbook air is
the base model with the seven
core gpu not the eight core so it's
scoring almost
19 000 in metal we've actually seen the
8 core get around
22 000 which is really impressive but
even with the 7 core
we are getting 57 percent faster
graphics performance so if what you do
really relies on the graphics and you
take that very seriously
the macbook air is the obvious choice
now finally let's go ahead and get into
gaming
of course on the ipad pro you can play
your ipad games you can play at 120 fps
however on the macbook air everything's
changing because you can now play
those same games on the macbook air as
you can see we're in the mac app store
i've switched to iphone and ipad apps
and as you can see we have a bunch of
games however not all games show up
which is unfortunate
but for that we have this app i
mazing what you do is you grab a cable
and you connect your iphone or your ipad
to the mac and you log in i'll show you
guys all right i'm plugging in the ipad
there you go it connected i'm going to
hit trust on the ipad pro
and right here it is now pairing to the
ipad this is actually a paid app
but you do get a 14 day trial so that's
really nice
you click on the ipad you go over to
manage apps
then you switch to library and then you
find
the games that you want to download we
have these four i'm going to right click
download to library all right now the
apps have finished downloading you right
click
and you click export ipa
and you put it into your applications
folder i want to connect
our xbox controller so there you go the
xbox controller is connected and let's
go ahead and open up brawlhalla so there
you guys go there's brawlhalla it is
running
as you can see the controller support is
working now the biggest issue is the
aspect ratio is messed up
and we can't go into full screen mode
that's because the current version of
big
sur does not support this now in my
other video on the macbook pro i
downloaded the developer beta
and full screen was working perfectly so
if you did not watch that gaming review
of the macbook pro with the m1
definitely go and watch that but as you
guys can see
we're getting this small little box but
controller support
is working which is very nice so for
games like this that
support controllers you're going to have
no issues at all
playing them on the m1 macbook air
because obviously it's
fanless we're sitting at only 37 degrees
the cpu and gpu are barely being used
for a game like this
in fact in the previous gaming review i
ran four games at once
and it was no issue at all now i do want
to show you guys
call of duty mobile now i would highly
suggest not using your main account
create
another one because there is a chance
that you could get banned
playing cod mobile on the mac and what's
really awesome is that apple created
automatic click to touch translation
so clicking on the trackpad and swiping
gets translated to
touch input that you would do on the
ipad and now we're finally in game and
as you can see
we got controller support finally
now this isn't as nice because we can't
go into full screen
without that developer beta build of big
sur
but as you can see it's working
incredibly well and
no issues at all very well optimized
i also installed clash royale so let's
test that out as well
here you go clash royale is working and
the automatic translation works
perfectly for a game like this
simple touch based games where you just
need basically one finger
to move around and swipe as you can see
it's working
perfectly well but there is one
type of game or one category of game
that does not work very well and i'm
going to show you guys brawl stars
now this type of game is not great
because it's meant to be used with a
touchscreen with two hands as you can
see
i have the toggle over here to move but
then i have a fire one over here
and you can't do both at the same time
with a trackpad or even a mouse
you have to switch back and forth so for
these types of games
it is not a great experience on the mac
and i don't think it will be
until controller support is added now of
course the mac has
access to games that are available on
mac os
better games potentially even aaa titles
as you can see we have the battle.net
client right here and we have diablo 3
installed here we are in game and it's
smooth
the performance is great we're running
at a little bit lower than
native resolution instead of 2560 by
1600
i'm down to 2048 by 1280. i mean
this is decent decent performance
playing on a fanless macbook air
this is with the seven core gpu not the
eight core which is
surprising so as you guys can see we're
going through this
with no issues everything's super smooth
it looks to be 60 fps right now as you
can see 42 degrees celsius
i played for about half an hour the
hottest that it got playing diablo 3 was
50 degrees celsius
not 100 like the intel as you guys can
see i downloaded
world of warcraft and it runs natively
so let's run it we're set to native
resolution
100 resolution scale and set to the
middle point
five which is recommended for this
system now
as we're moving around i don't know if
you can see but we're getting
52 fps right now now if we turn it down
to
three hit apply we are now set to
basically consistent 60 fps
now what's shocking about this is that
there's no fan in this macbook air and
let me show you guys
the stats 47 degrees celsius right now
using
27 of the cpu and 60
of the gpu here you go i just joined a
battleground
let's check out the fps sitting at still
60 57 fps now earlier i also tested
a dungeon and in that dungeon at the
level 3
setting for graphics i was getting 60
fps as well
at 5 i was getting around 40 45
so i'd say setting it down to three is
perfect for this macbook air
and as you guys can see the cpu is still
at 46 degrees celsius 47 that's just
crazy
earlier i played for about half an hour
or longer the most i saw it go to was
around 50
51 degrees celsius so that was just
shocking and i'd say
personally for gaming between these two
yes the ipad pro is more convenient
and comfortable for using all types of
games but you don't have access to these
aaa games like you do on the macbook air
so in my personal opinion i would rather
use the macbook for gaming
so with all of that tested and out of
the way let me give you my opinion
on which one of these you should buy so
the ipad pro setup is
eleven hundred dollars actually twelve
hundred thirty dollars
if you want the apple pencil now this
comes with 128 gigs of storage
compared to 250 for the macbook air
which costs a thousand dollars
so finally here's my answer if you like
touch based
go with the ipad pro but i highly
recommend waiting a couple more months
until around march
because we should be seeing a new ipad
pro with better performance and new
features
but for me i'm gonna go with the macbook
air
all day because it is a much more
capable device
and you could do so many more things
especially in terms of
gaming even using crossover to play
windows games as well
so for me it's gonna be this machine
because it can do
everything and the ipad pro can't
so there you guys go hopefully this long
video helped you make a decision
and if it did feel free to use the links
down below for the best deals
on the ipad pro the macbook air the
magic keyboard the apple pencil
there are deals on amazon all the time
so definitely check those links
thank you guys for watching please click
that circle above to subscribe
and check out those videos right over
there thanks for watching we'll see you
in the next video